foreign
this is talk TV
Toronto please New York as British prime
minister Liz truss clings on desperately
to power how much longer can this
ridiculous task continue
plus he's the king of ustv news and one
of the most influential conservatives on
the planet Tucker Carlson joins me
and one of the most explosive
Personalities in sporting history I'll
talk exclusively to Iron Mike Tyson
from New York this is it is Morgan
uncensored
well good evening to Piers Morgan and
censored from New York as Liz truss's
growth plan is blown to ashes and their
credibility reduced to Rubble Ukraine
sadly faces ruin of a very real kind
Putin is now pounding civilians with
Kamikaze drones a third of Ukraine's
power plants have been destroyed in a
week this is a calculated move to starve
freeze and Bully Ukraine into submission
yet today we learned that even the UK
support of Ukraine is now under threat
another devastating consequence of
truss's Reign of error defense secretary
Ben Wallace one of the last few credible
Tories left is here in the U.S for talks
on the war today his deputy said this
we here in the ministry of Defense are
doing a good job of keeping our nation
safe at a time of incredible Global
insecurity my boss Ben Wallace is in
Washington this morning uh having the
sort of conversations that
beyond belief really the fact that we're
at a time when these sort of
conversations are necessary well it's
beyond belief no wonder both Ian Wallace
have reportedly threatened to quit trust
promised a double defense spending now
the new chance to Jeremy Hunt says no
budget saved from cuts the cuts he'll
have to make because the government's 20
billion pounds worse off than before
trust took office even after demolishing
a disastrous budget it's not just
Defense number 10 says trust is no
longer committed to increasing pensions
either but the only thing she seems
committed to is squatting in Downing
Street saving her own skin and she made
clear on a toe curling BBC interview
I will lead the conservatives into the
next general election definitely
well look
I'm not focused on internal debates
within the conservative party what the
hell is she laughing at none of this is
funny for some people it might literally
be deadly serious David Cameron gave us
the age of austerity and it was very
painful this will be known as the age of
trusterity because there's only one
person to blame for this mess and every
day that Liz trust clings to power
Britain gets poorer
well my first guest tonight there's a
thing or two about taking down failing
politicians he's one of the most
colorful and controversial people in
American TV news and when he speaks
Millions listen
he's the king of cable news in America
and one of the most influential
conservatives in the world who are these
people do they mean us harm is that
simply a matter of competing for jobs
with American citizens it's potentially
a grave threat for five years and over a
thousand hours of Primetime television
Tucker Carlson's been the voice of
American outrage more than three million
people watch him every night on Fox
where he defies consensus defies Elites
and defies censorship it's hard to think
of an ideal more American than the
freedom of speech to the left is
probably going to be number one a
phrases and ideas that are really core
to the racist white nationalist
movements he wants you to believe the
concern about white supremacy in America
is a hoax which is very convenient for a
guy whose show has been dabbling in it
for years his fans he's a straight
talking Superstar asking the questions
nobody dares to ask what is this really
about why do I hate Putin so much has
Putin ever called me a racist tonight
for once he's going to be answering my
questions and it's uncensored
well I've done it to say that sir Tucker
Carlson joins me now Tucker thank you so
much for joining the show again oh
thanks for having me Pierce I want to
start by I've got Mike Tyson on the show
after you Tucker and Tyson probably the
two most infamous American pugilists
only in very different ways you verbally
him physically you're gonna think
sometimes you're living the life of Mike
Tyson with the the Rough and Tumble of
American cable news
no my my Mike Tyson plays for Keeps I've
always loved Mike Tyson I know I'm a
boxing fan and there were a lot of
people in the boxing world who were
appalled by Mike Tyson because they
thought effectively he was too Savage I
always admired Mike Tyson's boxing
um so but no that's not even I mean I
work in a very gentlemanly low-stakes
world compared to Mike Tyson you know I
watched your solos as I often do and I
looked for the devil I looked for this
person that your critics scream about
morning noon and night this appalling
human being I didn't find him I found
somebody engaged in Spirited opinion uh
most of which actually last night I
happen to agree with somebody who was
very courteous to his guests uh
respectful of their opinions listen to
them
um where do you get this reputation from
and do you care
well to answer the second question first
obviously I don't care I wouldn't be
doing it I care what people I love think
of me I care deeply about it I'm
controlled by really to a great extent
by my desire to please the people I love
it's not a huge group of people but I
have a lot of children and and a wife
and friends and staff and I love them
all and so I do care what they think I
do not care what Strangers think I'm not
sure why I should as for you know how
I'm perceived obviously we don't see
ourselves clearly I I know you know this
very well having lived in public life
for many decades
um but from my perspective I'm very
moderate I don't want radical change of
any kind I'm an American I've lived here
all my life I always think I like 1985
for example this was a happy prosperous
country people were pretty reasonable
they tolerated disagreement with others
they didn't hate their neighbors because
they voted for someone different and I
want to return to that that's my goal if
that's fascism okay fine but that's
that's what I want I don't want a
revolution at all I'm the opposite of a
revolutionary I'm temperamentally
conservative I want to conserve the good
things about my country and that's how I
feel and I would say also that in
general I'm I can certainly be a jerk I
have been in public many times but in
general I like other people and I have
no interest in being rude I believe in
politeness so I don't see myself as a
radical divisive figure in the slightest
I see myself as kind of a moderate
middle-aged guy in a v-neck sweater
and you sport that sweater very well
Tucker if I may say so
I want to turn to the state of our two
countries really because they're joined
I think in one sense by two leaders who
many people believe have literally
fallen asleep at the wheel I want to
play a little match up for you this is
of President Biden and our prime
minister for the moment Liz Truss
I'm sorry but given the speed at which
things move to the weekend I haven't had
time uh
[Music]
I will leave the conservatives into the
next camera definitely
because of the actions we've taken
things have begun to change
and Dakota how many people voted for
your plan
[Music]
what do you mean by that
what do you mean by that
now what struck me uh Tucker about both
leaders from these clips is a the
extraordinary delusion that they are
somehow doing a brilliant job but
secondly how do we get to a place where
America and the UK two of the great
countries of the world where there is
such a pulsity of talent available in
the political Arena you end up with
these kind of leaders who by Common
consent are at best mediocre and
certainly in the case of our prime
minister right now of just six weeks
completely and utterly useless
that is the obsession of my life how did
great and impressive countries filled
with hundreds of millions of great
impressive people wind up led by the
worst among them and look I mean I think
we should start with the obvious which
is the democracy is not real in the west
the majority doesn't get what it wants
consistently over time obviously that's
how you know leadership makes all the
difference if you have good leaders
you've got prosperous happy stable
countries and if you don't you have the
opposite so leadership really matters
clearly the systems that we've had in
place post-war for the last 80 years to
raise up talent and put it in positions
to rule over the rest of us that system
is very flawed it's producing instead
short-sighted day traders who have no
real investment in the countries they
lead no long-term vision for those
countries and no moral strength they're
weak and weak leadership in the home as
in the nation results in disaster if you
have parents who can't make a decision
you know you have kids who are out of
control and the same is true in Nations
and that's what we're seeing but we need
a total revamp of the system in the UK I
would say in the whole anglosphere I
would add New Zealand Australia Canada
to that list because those are the
countries that have fallen the farthest
the English-speaking world
all those countries need to rethink how
they're raising up leaders because it's
not working no I mean I saw an
extraordinary clip of the weekend to
President Biden munching an ice cream
which is never a good look for a man
actually in public but also what he said
was so extraordinary let's take a look
at it again
well it's predictable I mean it was I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake
anyway I just think I I disagreed with
the policy but that's up to Great
Britain to make that judgment not only
what I loved about this target was there
was President Biden who is presiding
over a shambolic economy in America
Again by Common consent taking the high
moral ground as if somehow he's some
great economic Guru the British prime
minister is completely clueless well I
don't disagree with him but I don't
think he's a position to say that
frankly given what's going on here but
again he he clearly believes he's
absolutely nailing it when in fact what
he is doing is nailing most People's
Bank balances well I think that's
exactly right you have this weird cycle
and you see it again all over the
English-speaking world you see it in New
Zealand maybe most clearly this idyllic
country with virtually no big problems
run really into the ground by leaders
who not only don't care about the future
of the country they run but are totally
unwilling to acknowledge their failures
it is this kind of syndrome where the
more exposed they are as ineffective and
incompetent and in some cases I would
say Sinister the more tightly they cling
to the fiction that everything is great
it really is you know in the old cliche
the band on the deck of the Titanic I
mean they're gonna play their music
until they sink beneath the waves it's
this is a disaster like if you again if
you ran your personal life this way you
would have no real relationships if you
made a mistake and never admitted it and
no it's always your fault you would be
without friends you know no one could
bear to be with you and but that's what
they're like
the big question I think for British
viewers in particular about America
right now is what is going to happen
with Donald Trump what do you think is
going to happen is he going to run again
for president and if he did would that
be a good or bad thing for the Democrats
well I think that the Democratic party
has re-energized Donald Trump and his
voters by sicking the Department of
Justice on him and raiding his home uh
which they did in August and I think
that reminded people that maybe the
thing they like best about Trump is how
much he is hated by the people in charge
that really is his great strength they
hate him
um I don't know if he's going to run or
not I keep hearing that he is and that
he will announce by the end of this year
2022. I I can't confirm that I don't
think however that the people currently
in charge will sit by and allow that to
happen if they can help it I mean I
really think they plan to Hound Trump uh
into dropping out of politics forever
he's not because he's some sort of
threat to the federal bureaucracy no
Trump's threat excuse me is that he's
willing to say what he really thinks
he is uncontrolled and they hate that
that's completely true
um we've got a banner at the moment
saying Tucker Carlson uncensored quite
clearly you've never been censored I'm
not entirely sure I have but we call the
show appears more nonsense in any way
um on censorship on Free Speech I think
I share your belief it's probably never
been under greater attack than it is
today and in a way the kind of illiberal
Liberals are behaving like they're very
fascists they profess to hate and they
want to dictate how we should all be
thinking and what we should all be
saying and the consequences if we don't
sign up to this kind of ultra woke world
view is that you get shame vilified and
canceled but my question for you is not
that because I I think we agree about
how Insidious this is to society but
where is your line for this and in
particular I'll give an example in in
the news recently of Alex Jones that the
shock jog I've had a few run-ins with
him before
um this whole case of the Sandy Hook uh
families who sued him and got nearly a
billion dollars what did you make of the
that did you feel that he crossed a line
which should not be acceptable even if
you believe passionately in free speech
that if you basically spew lies which I
think he knew to be lies for massive
commercial gain and inflict endless new
misery on grieving families to the
extent they get death threats and so on
did he cross a line
well sure I mean I would never defend it
I mean to extend I understand what he
said which I don't really but I mean
clearly he said things that wounded that
hurt the feelings of the Sandy Hook
families and that's bad and I would
never defend that I live in a country
where the people with actual power not
Alex Jones but people who run the
Federal Reserve and the federal
government and the Pentagon lie every
single day about things that really
really matter they lied about the Corona
virus for two years and really destroyed
the American economy and killed people
and they were never held to account the
Federal Reserve shaved 30 percent off
the value of the US dollar and nobody
was indicted so like yes I'm against
lying I try not to engage in it myself I
really do try actually
um but people do lie and it's sort of a
hierarchy of of of crime here I mean
like the people who tell the biggest
lies get to remain on television spewing
their self-righteousness and the people
at the margins who criticize them who
get caught lying are silenced so this is
censorship censorship only benefits the
people in power it's always an attack on
the weak always that's what this is
they use the civil code civil lawsuits
to silence people they don't like it's
happened to me thankfully I work for a
big company Fox which has defended me
but if I didn't you know I'd be silenced
and impoverished because they would sue
me for lying and hurting people in words
or violence the truth is words are not
violence violence is violence shooting
people is bad they don't have a problem
with that our murder rate in American
cities has gone up 40 in a year thanks
to their policies they don't care they
don't care about actual violence what
they care about is any threat to their
hegemony to their power and Alex Jones I
guess they thought presented some threat
to that so they crushed him I mean
that's what's really going on and I say
that as someone who does you know I
don't think you should like criticize
the families of children who were
murdered obviously I think that's in
very bad taste but it's not violence
the other person that we're debating
later on the show who has an issue with
the truth and in particular in espousing
truthful statements is Meghan Markle uh
the debate we're going to be having is
whether Americans have had their fill of
the Duchess of Sussex as an American do
you have a view
well I always thought she was ridiculous
and I felt sorry for
the Brits I mean I am you know I guess
by birth partly English I mean my
ancestors came from there and so I don't
I don't follow it super carefully but I
love your literature and I've always
admired your culture and and I and I'm
you know broadly speaking I guess
sympathetic to the continuity that the
real family represents and so from my
perspective as an American I look at
Meghan Markle and I'm like this is a bad
idea why how did you fall for that this
chick's from La she's a failed actress
she's clearly
acting out of bad intent she wants to
destroy things she didn't build and I
just never understood why anyone I mean
I thought she was like a ridiculous
narcissist and the first words I heard
emerged from her mouth like it never
occurred to me to take her seriously and
I and I watched with shock as you got
fired over calling her to account for an
obvious life and then
I watched this one of your friends got
fired for trying to defend you I just
interviewed her the other day the whole
thing was so insane historians were
right about this it was Preposterous uh
Tucker great to have you on the program
thank you very much for taking the time
I really appreciate it thanks for having
me
all the best
well next time how do you follow Tucker
cars well what about the baddest man on
the planet he's not so bad now he's a
good guy now Mike Tyson on Trump Putin
pigeons who knows I just want him to do
one thing Mike stay awake this time
because last time I interviewed you you
fell asleep
I'm going to talk to you about that it's
pretty interesting
we'll talk to you after the break mate
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan censor from
New York I am Mike Tyson I've done an
extraordinary life of Triumph and
tragedy on both the front and back pages
he was the King of the Ring 44 Knockouts
and Undisputed World Heavyweight
Champion and for me the greatest boxer
of them all he's always unmissable
television the last time I interviewed
him it looked like he'd just been
knocked out himself
I'm going to just want to do this I plan
on doing this for a charity exponent and
I think I'm capable of doing that and
that's what I want to do
but perhaps
the heavens raised about the fact that
you are two men in your 50s uh fighting
each other without protective headgear
what what do you think about those
concerns
I think it's very wonderful that we're
fighting together that the fight that we
should have
well I can see you laughing there uh
Mike Tyson hey thank you for joining me
again you look a lot perkier today than
you did then Mike what was going on last
time
Hey listen I was I had hurt myself at
that particular time I guess I was
training something to happen I hurt
myself and
I I'll be seeing some painkillers from
My Wife and after I received these
painkillers
I was just uncapable of articulating
anything it was just a mess
people thought I was so boring as an
interviewer that I'd literally driven
you to sleep
[Music]
it was my fault everybody it was my
fault I need you to take the rap for
this one mate because I got killed for
that it was like Morgan you're just
sending people to sleep what's the
matter with you uh it's great to see you
again mate first of all how are you we
I've been watching you fighting it was
fantastic and the next thing I saw
you're in a wheelchair because you've
had bad sciatica blow up and stuff how's
your health generally yeah
man it's Splendid right now I've been
training every day I've been working out
I've been slightly watching what I'm
eating I feel wonderful
well that's great to hear um I want to
talk to you about a number of things but
first of all I want to talk to you about
uh Ukraine uh the reason being that I
went out there recently and I met with
both the Klitschko brothers two great uh
World Heavyweight Champions themselves
one is the mayor of key the capital city
of Ukraine fighting to to save that City
his brother has actually been on the
front line occasionally as well what do
you feel about that these guys that you
know have been such great champions in
the ring are now literally fighting for
their freedom
yes I I I'm I'm a great deal of respect
from those two fighters
and they're champions in the fight for
their country as well
what do you feel about this war Mike
what do you what do you think should
happen
I think um it should it shouldn't be a
war anymore
do you think that what Putin did was
wrong
I don't know what Putin did
but I I don't think they should be
fighting
what about domestic politics here in
America Mike there's a lot of turbulence
a lot of people very angry at the moment
possibly made worse by the pandemic in
being locked away and not being able to
see loved ones or something a lot of
anger in society what do you make of
that
I believe during all
um political competition
it's always ugly
but do you feel it's getting worse do
you feel like tribalism between people
is getting worse the ability to listen
to other opinions and not get furious is
getting worse
I think everybody
and it
um she just worked together
and build a conglomerate
how do we do that do you think
okay by trusting and loving one another
look how far we came since the 80s
and we're going to continue to go
further and further I'm really I'm
really positive and about this country
let's continue I love going in the
future right A lot of people are
negative about America why are you
positive
um it's the country in my home I believe
in it and I believe it's going to really
um flourish after this pandemic is truly
over
how did you find the pandemic might
being locked locked down and not able to
see loved ones and so on
well I don't like if I could say and be
permitted I really
um flourished during the pandemic I
really um
I that's when I became a great um
advocate for charity
because I was just very grateful what
happened during the pandemic why were
you grateful
and because I was able to help people
that couldn't be helped right
in what way were you doing that
I'm just charity fooled on the line
coach jacket
um book bags
back to school programs
it's quite a shift for you isn't it to
go from the baddest man on the planet
that was your fighting title that's what
your great coach customer wanted you to
feel so that you were Invincible in the
ring you go from that guy to a guy who
in a very difficult time for the world
uh was so Keen to help everybody else to
to be charitable towards them
well I had I had a great trainer to
teach me how to be a great fighter
and now I have a great teacher to teach
me how to great
um
humanitarian
when you think about your journey Mike
your life how you've how you've evolved
as a human being
what place have you reached now are you
happy in yourself
hey um I'm very happy and I'm very proud
of myself
I I never understood my accomplishments
as a human being until last year perhaps
I never took myself serious and last
year I tried and it turned out really
well
what did you learn about yourself what
have you what have you worked out about
yourself
that was a scared little boy for a long
time
and you're not scared anymore
no because that scary little boy is
really vicious and mean and scared
how have you found peace would you say
my family
that's my greatest accomplishment
being a father being a husband
yeah I'm just the whole the whole thing
man
how do you spend your days now Mike
my days yeah um I do it I do it I do
anything I want
what's an average day for Mike Tyson
these days
um first thing get up worked out for two
or three hours
come back take a shower eat my breakfast
most of it is
um I don't know plant-based
and then um I may may go to work with my
wife and may do some interviews
listen I had some great interviews
yesterday
's X
tiger
and Leslie Jones
well I didn't pass yesterday I did it I
did a great interview with you in your
hot box for your podcast it was
fascinating yes you did a great one
great one and you're always welcome us
too I would love to do it again we had
an amazing fascinating Chapman I would
say to people that you're a very you're
a complex human being but you've got a
massive heart an extraordinary work
ethic and I don't think I've seen many
people who've evolved as a human being
more than you have given the tough
upbringing you had to where you've come
to today
hey I just think of it from this
perspective
the great the greatest talent that God
gives you he gives you a lot of flaws to
go with it as well
do you think all great human beings are
flawed
in order to succeed they have to be
flawed
they have to experience some kind of
shame in their life
that won't allow them to be in the
position they believe was overwhelming
to them psychologically and emotionally
and physically
who are the people in history Mike that
you
most respect for whatever reason
Alexander the Great
um Elijah Muhammad
um Jesus Prophet Muhammad Moses I have
an array of great people that I like
flavius Bella Ferris it's just so many
people that is
I don't know Charlemagne Pippin
Charles Martel you know I can go a ray
ray of people who I admire Genghis Khan
Kubla King he's just so many great
people I love
outfit I look I read about them every
day
what is the what is the trait in a human
being you most admire is it an ability
to bounce back from adversity
well that's good too that's really
flamboyant and people think it's great
but a human being his greatest ability
and the ability to love
Mike I'm going to take a short break
come back I want to talk to you about
this extraordinary incident on a plane
where for some reason oh yeah a very
annoying passenger decide to to well
annoy you and he got his comeuppance
we'll talk about that in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
with Mike Tyson formerly the baddest man
on the planet but now a very different
man as we've just established mate
you're on a plane minding your own
business when another passenger for
reasons that continue to baffle me
decided to go to Let's remind viewers
what happened
hey Mike Mike come on let's go turn that
way
here you go no I guess they're watching
it right now
Mike that incident ended exactly how I
expected it to once the idiot started
mocking you in that way uh what were you
thinking as you sat there when this guy
was doing what he was doing
first of all I came from this place
where I um it was called hippie Hill
where at least 60 000 people were there
and we're all smoking cannabis okay so
by the time I'm on the plane I'm high
hungry and tired okay and this guy keeps
um antagonizing me right and then
I came to my fences
and kicked
no I'm only joking I want to joke I wish
I had nothing but you know you got to be
careful
I know I ain't taking that but my my my
My Bodyguard jumped on top of him and I
was saying my bodyguard
which I'm sorry
[Laughter]
uh what I imagine you've achieved Mike
is that nobody will annoy you on a plane
again
no listen that guy was just being um
irritate really
talking about and you have to hit me
with a water bottle that my wife remind
me of right
yeah I mean completely pathetic Behavior
you shouldn't have been doing it do you
get a lot of this kind of stuff when you
go around
10 people I may get one
how many do you deal with
quite a few but I may only have to put
my hands on one
or something
well your wife is a delightful lady I've
had the great pleasure of meeting her
um do you think do you think she keeps
you out of trouble now Mike
well I think she thinks she keeps me out
of trouble I'm just always with her so
that's why I'm not in trouble
but if she wasn't with you more people
would get a smack
no I don't agree on that I guess I would
my wife always told me to be nice when I
go outside so I would take that advice
and be nice
it's a true love mate
excuse me what's the secret of true love
bad memory
[Laughter]
are you are you a romantic manner
big time yeah
because you're you know your wife I've
seen you together you're very much in
love with each other how do you how do
you show your love for her
me I buy a house
that would make me love you
Oh Hey listen man I'm busting shots
I'm uh I help her as a parent and we
co-parent our kids simultaneously every
day
and what what kind of values might do
you try and teach your kids
excuse me what kind of values do you
teach your children
you have to be spiritually they haven't
gone but never give up and just deal
with life is just a long line of puzzles
that need to be solved
and then without that um competition
spirit
people are not going to do well and they
have to know about competition because
without competition and train them they
give in under the slightest struggle
right so I've been talking about this a
lot because I think we are creating a
soft environment for kids which doesn't
help them you know at school now if they
come last in any competition they get a
praise you know it's always about how
they're feeling if they lose they're not
allowed to lose anymore and I'm like
exactly
there's a scene in Rocky which I love in
the sixth movie when Rocky finally has
it out with his son and he says to look
life is really tough you know and it's
going to hit you and hit you and hit you
and it's not about how hard you can hit
it's about how hard you can get hit and
get back up and keep moving forward and
I thought that was a really powerful
scene uh what do you think of that did
would you is that your kind of
philosophy
yes it is a hundred percent only one
thing is different it's a small it's
just a small fundamental difference and
that is once life hit me I'm gonna hit
life back yes
yeah I mean that's that is a I I don't
disagree with that if people hit you why
should you take it that's always been I
know your mantra
I mean just
who I am
Mike at various stages of your life I'm
just me right and you've never I've
known you a long time and I find you one
of the Most Fascinating People I know
you've had periods in your life where
you've been unbelievably rich like half
a billion dollars and so on you've had
other times when you've had no money
when have you been happiest with with a
lot of money or actually is money
irrelevant to your happiness
well I was happy both
um incidents
but it was just a part of my growing
stage
um
I um I wasn't experienced with my money
when I was younger I'm more experienced
now
when you uh I think it's 25 years since
you bit Evander hollifield's ear
and I did really yeah certainly 25 years
yeah it's a long time right
I agree
do you know what happened to it to that
bit of his ear
but then in the fighting you um it was
able
obvious for you to see me spit it out
wasn't it yeah I just wonder what
happened to it
I don't know um I think they picked it
up and they put some I don't know what
it was a mile die
and I gave it to him in a commercial
[Laughter]
I read somewhere that you'd made 30
million dollars from posing for pictures
pretending to bite people
listen
I don't know it was 30 but it was more
than three that I got to um fine for
I've actually got a picture of you
trying to bite me it's on my Lou wall
hey
Hey listen that's the new um that's the
new gimmick picture every time kids
ladies men elderly men elderly ladies
take a picture make my hand take a
picture of this stuff and um I'm happy
to be able to do it
well you left my ear alone I'm I'm glad
to say uh Mike you're you're in great
she didn't pay me for it
[Laughter]
a quick question before I let you go
Donald Trump uh we we think may run
again for president you backed him last
time would you back him again
Hey listen
I'ma do what I want to do when he runs
for president
but it's gonna be nobody else business
you're not going to say either way
there's nobody business what I say but
I'm gonna say something
it's getting your head above the parapet
on politics more dangerous than getting
in the ring
no it's just ridiculous it's like
if if I don't like you I don't make the
whole country not like you
and I might send you to jail too
I mean it is ridiculous and what's also
ridiculous mate is that we can't have an
opinion anymore right you're on a show
now called Piers Morgan uncensored you
can say what the hell you like but you
try and say some things out of this
environment and people want to cancel
you
it's like a what is this um I don't know
this fascist if the government don't
like you the corporate world don't like
you is that is that called fashion it's
fascism yeah it is
oh yeah that's what it is then it could
listen if certain people don't like you
oh he's a bad guy you know I'm not gonna
let it work for my company no more and
he gives you a bad name to all the
corporations and you can't make any
money just because there's one
Corporation doesn't like you
absolutely right it's it's absurd the
way Society has gone Mike I could talk
to you all night but I've got to leave
it there thank you very much for being
with me and for being so completely on
fire compared to last time I'm just so
glad that you didn't fall asleep forgive
me please
me and my wife was viewing it and oh man
so I'm so ashamed my if more you've more
than made up for it this time thank you
very much great to talk to you take care
Bears all the best
well coming next is America a sick of
the sussexes as I am that debate after
the break
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
New York moaning Meghan Markle struck
again today using a latest podcast to
complain she was objectified in her role
as a briefcase girl on America's Deal or
No Deal a job that when she was
literally paid to wear a nice dress and
hold a briefcase that's what the job was
and I would end up leaving with this pit
in my stomach knowing that I was so much
more than what was being objectified on
the stage
I didn't like feeling forced to be all
looks
and little substance
and that's how it felt for me at the
time
being reduced
to this specific archetype
last thing we want is for you to feel
that way Maggie will joining me now is
formatory MP Louise Mensch Fox News
contributor captain and Fox News host
Geraldo Rivera what an extraordinary
panel we have today uh and some unlikely
Defenders of Miss marker will come to in
a moment first of all cat uh Meghan
Markle every time she and Harry I think
they've reached a nadir of
self-aggrandizing self-absorbed nonsense
aren't they popular something even more
ridiculous yeah and the way she talks
about this is this she's describing some
really serious trauma that she went
through she had to open a briefcase and
that's all that she had to do also had
to yeah you're paid to look attractive
that's what the job is you know when you
sign up and to say she was forced to do
it no you agreed to take the job to me
this makes about as much sense as
accepting a job at Subway and saying
it's sexist when a man asks you to make
him a sandwich that is what you were
paid to do and plenty of women who do
that job they're grateful for it they
like it they're finally with it so if
that's what you want to do choose to do
it if you don't don't but it's not a
trauma not liking your job yeah I mean
Louise what they do to pair of them they
are professional victims they turn every
single thing in their life into this
terrible drama as cat says and play the
victim card intensely all the time but I
don't feel remotely sorry for them about
any of it well why should you I mean
didn't she get a clue when she saw the
length of the hemline on that red dress
right she wasn't exactly being on to get
asked on to give her thoughts on world
politics every night
um look is it a bit sexist yeah I guess
so but women aren't the only ones
objectified I mean when I was uh I get
it all the time I'm sure you're so
dashing and geraldo's exactly yeah but
you know I used to drool over Arnold
Schwarzenegger my brother had a picture
of him in Commando on the back of his
room used to go in and and leer at him
pop stars uh footballers there's not all
these girls but the women like bleating
at them because they're sex objects it's
not a tragedy if a member of the other
sex finds you attractive could you just
calm down for five minutes well let's
ask around Aranda you are you've been
young to many a woman's desires over the
year
I was a younger man let's address that
point first of all about the
objectifying I mean if you take a job
like that on Deal or No Deal can you
really then Bleak years later about the
terrible trauma of being victimized and
objectified
to me this is just the latest in a long
series of incidents involving Megan and
Harry Piers with all due respect that
the critics of the couple sees on to
make them uh you know seem narcissistic
and self-involved and uh and Petty
people that's because back in the 1990s
well maybe uh I I tend to have a
different opinion but back in the 1990s
uh my ex-wife and I were friends with
Sarah Ferguson yeah Sarah had uh just uh
left prince Andrew uh and it it seemed
to me that the Press was all over her in
a way that was that was really malignant
they tried to destroy her and now she's
built back her reputation now she's
probably you know she's certainly more
popular than prince Andrew is the friend
of Jeffrey Epstein there but I I think
some of that same unfairness is now
pulling down on Megan and I I I do
believe that there is an aspect of Truth
uh to uh to a kind of resistance to
Megan because she's not the typical
spouse of a royal I mean well I would
say that I think you say that I would
say that the problem that they both have
is people but certainly in Britain they
don't like the fact that they've taken
their Royal titles out of the country
they don't perform any of the duties
which you're supposed to do in return
for the titles they're making tens if
not hundreds of millions of dollars from
companies like Netflix and Spotify and
so on and most of it involves them
trashing the royal family and the
monarchy the monarchy of course which is
the reason they had the titles that they
can make all the money so there's a
hypocrisy and a kind of commercial greed
about it which really wrangles with
people
I I can understand that criticism but I
remember following Prince Harry into
helmet province in Afghanistan where he
had just served with great distinction
and courage uh fighting against the uh
the Taliban and one of the most
dangerous places on Earth I mean there
is an aspect of this couple that is far
more uh uh agreeable or or appealing uh
than the cliche the cartoon I think that
is somehow drawn of them and I do think
that you cannot leave that controversy
behind without having some discussion on
the plausibility that the race of Meghan
Markle and of the child uh children uh
is a is an issue okay whether you talk
about it or not it is an issue well I
think you could talk about it I just
don't I don't think it's an issue in the
way that they try and categorize it I
mean I've never felt any of the
antipathy towards Meghan Markle is
driven by her mixed race background I
think anyone cared about that it's it's
the way she's behaved not the skin color
right especially because if you look at
the life that she has and you look at
the life of the average person the
average person is going to look at her
and Oliver millions and millions of
dollars and all of the prestige that she
has and say and yet all this person can
do is constantly complain I don't think
I've ever heard her say something
positive no no it's not just oh yeah
that's about how lucky I am SOB's story
just this very intense she's never even
just a little sad everything's the worst
thing the worst life you got it you
gotta You Gotta Get a Grip she has to
get a grip so he's final word on this I
mean I think most people in Britain are
sick and tired of them and if Harry's
book trashes the Royals and the Netflix
documentary tries to the rules I think
it's game over for them back home you
and I both from East Sussex and it
rankles to happen we've been there more
than they are indeed exactly it rankles
to have them have the names of the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex I'll tell you the
way that Megan and Harry could win over
the British public give up your titles
all of your titles stop being
hypocritical and become Mr and Mrs
mountbatten Windsor and we will respect
hurray thank you Luis thank you Kat
thank you Herald of your spirit in
defense
you nearly changed my mind but
ultimately you did but thank you very
much indeed for joining me that's it for
me what are you up to keep it on
censored we'll be back here tomorrow
night from you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]